hey there hello everybody
what is up we're back you joined us
earlier thank you for joining us but now
we're back we're gonna be playing some
man of Madonn which is a horror game oh
yes
and there's also a multiplayer mode of
this horror game so I'm excited to check
it out I'm also scared but we'll see you
I'm very excited did you play until dawn
I did not okay so yeah what we're in for
hopefully a scary time until dawn was
like you know a bunch of kids up on a
mountain and we had like yetis and other
various horror movie beasts and then
this one's like I don't know some sort
of it is the man of it and I guess like
he's the monster
my understanding but I think we're in
for like some creepy mermaids and other
stuff we'll see but yeah the whole for
those for maybe Chad if you have not
played until dawn as well the whole deal
here is this is a horror game where we
get to make decisions and those
decisions are gonna greatly affect the
outcome of the game they might result in
players dying as well try not to die but
we'll see right now we have access to
two chapters pretty much this game will
be out on August 30th so this is not the
full builds this is just a little
preview a little taste of the horror
action so let's go ahead and start I
think I'm gonna I'm feeling like a
Charlie today okay so I'm gonna start
with Charlie
there's days ER for Charlie and I
believe we're starting just yeah it is
there okay actually it all blends
together when I'm out here all right so
I'm ready
I've hit okay now we did want to set up
this multi-screen setup here just so you
guys like can all see like from both
aspects our side and you know it's
multiplayer I want to see both sides
however the audio is only gonna come
from one game if this works out all
weird then we're just gonna switch to a
single camera view
ooh what I'm interested in seeing is how
this works out because from the trailer
like you make your own decisions and
that changes its thunderstorm there was
a storm is Rehan okay we've got the same
cutscene no we can uh I think we're I
think we might be controlling each other
our controller characters at the same
time doing different things perhaps like
I think we're all just hanging out on
this boat together
alrighty I'm already shook I had to
answer a question heist yeah we're
playing a little mana began in these
series of the dark pictures anthology
series from from supermassive games it's
a horror horror game for a game where
we're going to make some decisions that
hopefully don't result in us dying but
very well could
oh oh I just died I guys I didn't like
the first go are you about to get shot
over there yeah I think I was supposed
to do something but I was so into this
oh wow look at you away got me
alright I'm good I'm here to save you
this weird skin right into it here I
know also we're on a boat this person
just got on the boat somehow I guess
what a ninja yeah
Oh multiple people inaudible ninjas
ninja ninja few parrots yeah dang I
didn't react fast enough we're just
we're just getting right into it here
Wow Sydney's doesn't make all the bad
decisions you know for the best so far
that's how it's gone I'm pretty sure
that Sydney is this in me I think it is
from a friend of mine
ding I wonder if my side is saying
different dialogue
oh you're deciding something now I'm
gonna free you
I wonder you only know that's me because
my screens next to you like you wouldn't
be able to tell if that was me and I'm
like I told you who I was right maybe
yeah I don't know how many different
players because I assume I think you can
control everybody at some point so oh ok
uh-oh and now well I return the favor
yeah yeah got me I got you
[Music]
well I'm gonna help our friend first
yeah so anyway how you doing yeah I know
you you stay gagged yes it is said I
said all right now we talk oh wait we
have another prison - uncle I didn't
even see her before all right
I know they got it on camera before
we've got us all a man while we're
sleeping to our most vulnerable mm-hmm
please Oh ding maybe we should have
talked and got some info
maybe yeah cuz I don't know what's going
on
[Music]
almost free
I'm very limber getting out of your
bonds there well done don't get any
worse bad news is these are kind of
maybe the fishermen I pissed off earlier
of all your fault sorry
idiot Jesus
untie well I'm gonna incite you since
you brought them here yeah it is my
fault
this man this looks really nice too I
love how this looks I'm everything you
told Olmec really good because they did
like like rotoscoping over real actors
like rami malek was the big star that
one they all looks they look real good 2
gameplay screens Chris because we're
playing as two different characters here
right this is a multiplayer mode so
certain decisions in the story we are
gonna have to make on our own
yeah at some point we're gonna I think
diverge here once we escape I guess I
keep Smiley's eqing Smiley's oh no oh
that's what I get for trying to answer
someone's question this is a dev build
so we're only going to show an off yeah
to chapter 2 game here the game is out
on the 30 dang you got well and now
we're splitting [ __ ] yourself
the dark pictures mana bananas written M
for Mature
we already said I probably should have
put the imprimatur reading on this video
apology is in advance
oh man I'm watching you get beat up
through the window okay say nothing
shocked they're beating Conrad they're
just asking questions what you went with
yes what no I'm gonna counter pummeled
out here alright I want to know what's
up yeah
spicy dialogue dang we're missing my
dialogue right now though she asked me
something I have no idea
put on the subtitles oh we should
probably just do that let's put those on
subtitles noise alright awesome
yes good call okay alright
oh no that's that's gonna go down
alright okay easy
well I don't like what's going on here
oh I'm gonna lose the ear or Oh a piece
of your ears rates updated okay Oh ding
is that because I lost chunk of an ear
because I'm angry yeah but that okay but
traits updated I wonder if that was like
a significant moment there because I
have like butterfly effect moments and
until dawn and that's like when you knew
this is a decision that really matters
so I wonder if that's a reflective thing
there we'll save you
yeah so on our end over here we're
trying to break free Oh angry over here
but okay alright there's another well we
started later in the game we should say
this first chapter is about an hour into
the game sorry we don't know this cast
of characters because apparently there's
another dude oh yeah you you got body
yeah that's all oh great now she's not
gonna like
why didn't I even go over the door
handle not once
Oh dipstick dipstick [ __ ] oh I don't
think they're gonna they have an
influence flush sure seems to be getting
buddy-buddy with him okay have you seen
my brother
yeah I'm worried about my brother I
don't know he's one I guess he must be
the one under the bed that's the person
we've seen so I assume that's who that
is that's pretty funny King smile easy
that would be funny if the audio change
because my ear got cut oh let me kind of
need your hands once we get Julia back
maybe we could take it my surprise oh
man
[ __ ] real uh real deep thoughts st.
in that line what happened both your
parents so I guess so we only have the
option to play as Charlie and Joe here
right your Charlie I'm Joe I'm calling
you Conrad Oh Conrad yeah sorry so I
wonder if like in the full game we'd
have the option maybe the playing of
Julia here Gracie
oh we just have to wait and see what
they want to do with us
no Viking north gamer this game is not
out this is a def build the game comes
out on the 30th so very soon I'm very
excited loved until dawn
oh it's doing that classic trick you
count when the lightning hits and then
when you hear the Thunder take it
however many seconds is how many miles
away a storm is hey what's up goop good
to see you in chat goob yeah so there's
you can play the game alone you can do
uh you know let's take them out if we
play our cards right we can catch them
by surprise
take him out yeah let's do it I say with
my six-pack I'm doing it wrong do it
let's do it just Russia
take the gun let's do it oh man one of
us think I we had the gun they'd be
forced to surrender seven seconds I can
get out through the window we gotta
break these um so yeah there's you can
play the game alone you can play the
game like a pass the controller style
and you can climb around the side play
what we're doing for the others don't
leave us you're okay alright you're
about to go on a mission
two three
yeah it was the Thunder it wasn't us I
swear get it brain and neck I'll let me
be ready what the heck oh no I missed
I like this DISA cool you seen over here
oh that is cool rhythm oh no my brother
is gonna die because I miss I could
ditch you all but I'm not gonna do that
ah I grab the knife
okay barring updated that must be that
was like the butterfly
oh no I pushed the wrong button again
I'm clearly not paying attention and I'm
about to die that's gonna just slit my
throat please
I mean characters can die so that that
may happen man they caught me trying to
escape oh no this guy with the guns
looking at me all crazy although think
about what you're doing boy
both just get to the bloat I'm dead
I'm dead he's about to shoot me
you know go for it whoa that was not the
right move
that was the babe I might be the one who
dies no all right brother Allah correct
but Oh fell for it hate this use it if
you have to
music if you have to hit boy we're just
not we're not having a good time I know
you know I sit down just not paying
attention over there
IRL I would grab that night in time know
what I'm gonna make another adjustment
real quick here yeah go for it
let me J here we go brightness mmm we
ought to match up after that hopefully
let's see now it might still a little
bit darker mines on the left so you're
actually okay
well sure I do it tried to match me
their defaults to coops at jebaited Anna
Olson oh come here
what's that birth certificate
I feel like is more suspense than it is
horror so far well so far but there it
seems like it could have gone pretty
south there for a bit so
oh my god she's over here combing your
hair all right
June 21st baby still pointing his gun at
us
oh she was tending to your wounds excuse
me I appreciate it
um
oh I accidentally picked that one I was
gonna say you did your best
I just everything went so fast I tried
it it still should be the same story
shorty depending on how you play it but
you'll see different parts of it of
course there is no harm in just knock
you want to talk you know which
character you're planning to go up keep
the volume down
[Music]
hey come on we're just passing the time
no big deal
keep play I'm gonna keep pushing my luck
here I'm a little more reserved now that
guy oh I'm like yeah I was looking at
your eyes and I hit a and I was like oh
wait mine said B I look at yours every
time it's like your decision and I'm one
of these days I'm gonna one of these
times I'm gonna look over while you're
making a decision I'm gonna get like
shopping face because I didn't press
what did me this all time to you okay
you know what let's talk to this guy
he said no time to try anything and any
consequence
okay
that you're gonna weigh you can as you
learn discussing weather update over
kidnap oh dang
[Music]
you [ __ ] won't know the police
is gonna hunt you down
oceans of David
all right they're just out for money
y'all can't reason with people out for
money relationship update it
[Music]
and traits Oh
[Music]
I am dodging stuff flying around in the
basement right now I did it I almost
fell off there I did it but
it was cool
Oh day
wait we're flooding down here I don't
know how it's going up there on the deck
but we're flooding oh now he's letting
us out oh but leave it down push back in
by the waves yeah I saw that
that's my brother I gotta rescue my bro
she's ok we can still help her let's get
your brother out hey all right now
Oh ding
all right reunited we're back you made
it
Julia seems they have a bit of a limited
dictionary in this chain she's so mad we
didn't help her but she got a perfectly
random Silvana my pearl was like all the
way on the
there's the boat it's big ol hole in it
sure that's one way to pull up make an
engine
focus lay don't get knocked off the boat
you gonna always be ready oh well hey
there's all the important information
for you I want more well we got another
chapter right yes we Grail but for a
quick moment yeah let's get some full
screen action here yeah so uh that was
the first preview chapter man amadon you
could pre-order it now August 30 is is
when it comes out so definitely stay
tuned let's try this this second chapter
is it automatically gonna go into it or
no let's see it looks like we gotta do
some more invites yeah alright and so
and here's some of these out there uh
wait yeah don't play alone play alone we
don't want to play alone shared story
I'm gonna invite Tony real quick alright
man that was short okay so well I can't
tip their hat too much oh I think that
second part did we already see the
second part I think it's only one
chapter
I think Starman Duke of Milan or our one
thing what happens if we hit continue
there
yeah let's see oh wait no I don't or we
could just have one of us jump in and
we'll see what happens with just one oh
yeah let's see what let's see what the
single single player one is so we have
your audio so we'll switch through to
your cam here we go
yes Cooper I believe that is the same
actor from quantum break one of the one
of the teens on the boat oh that's I did
not want to do shared story of my fault
let's go back
I was gonna move the camera because we
do have subtitles on so alright play
them
oh man now I'm gonna be like just
counting down the days to the 30th yeah
let's see let's see how this differs now
we're only gonna get one perspective
right
all of this started very ominously but
then it just became very like
suspenseful instead of yeah Gary at some
point it definitely goes far more horror
with the monsters ofc yeah seeing the
screenshot oh yeah yeah definitely we're
gonna do everything right there we're
gonna hit all the prompts
look we're fightin back boom popping
bottles oh man exactly goob I won't miss
my QuickTime events this time because
I'm not even playing a lot it's all me
all right let's see
hmm not quite a sequel GX militia it is
in the same vein or were you know making
decisions and that could result in some
characters dying same kind of deal
different stories same gameplay and it's
the first of a couple games that they
actually I planned in this series so
I'll be excited to see what else they do
you know I'm very excited for this but
then after that you know they've got
more planned so alright let's bowl makes
me now you can pick whoever you want
yeah no pressure we'll go for that go
for some different stuff this time well
that's funny it looks like I could go
back and just say nah not you
[Music]
sorry we're gonna talk didn't you oh she
already knew here any news you guys this
is all my fault I'm sorry okay I'm sorry
okay so that's what this is we can see
where that is Iger what do you write
listen relaxed and I can just make him
look all around okay
dang our boy charlie is still taped up
so messed up so Jackson and the
multiplayer mode so far we kind of both
get control over certain decisions and
then those decisions together change I
guess the outcome of the the scene or
the story so when you do like the online
kind of thing when you're getting
multiple it's nice these are just super
cool me but then there's awful I still
have the controller just great untaped I
mean anyway what are they gonna do to us
No
get out of here not a teacher all right
we should be freed of them see much
ruckus Oh doll right that's it that time
[Music]
see that was my cue my story I was back
for you later nobody knows they're out
there living lady you're all alone with
us now let's make the most of it you can
go [ __ ] yourself you piece of [ __ ] oh
you're the little lady huh you're the
little lady I second that idea
oh yeah he you asked for that
all right let's see what happened the
last time I was very defiant I'm gonna
little this we're playing on PC right
now
Viking north gamer
all right well this yeah [ __ ] want
I like oh the options that give you are
all nice and calm and then he's just
hostile yeah but everyone wait I just
wanted to see it's like a fallout thing
where you choose dialogue option and
it's just so aggressive and Issei still
down easy
paying even as his mate is like
just stop me
we finish with it later all right I
didn't lose a chunk of my ear at that
time exactly treat updated ear intact
yes
I'm no longer eager but now I'm witty
guarded reckless slowly oh this boats
alright
I don't know why I always enjoyed that
up pause three we just make a character
look how around is like the sillies
thank you thank you Mario
that old Mario game oh yeah yeah Mario
64 are pulling his face yeah okay okay
okay gonna chill out this time
[Music]
I thought none of the guys noticed our
hands are in front of her now I mean
she's still found here yeah
snoop stick shut the [ __ ] up
dang even though the same time I heard
it still just as insulting very sighs
little dips to have a Netflix flush sure
seems to be getting buddy-buddy with him
let's see is this kind of staying here
now or go back up to the deck uh no I
didn't see him this time I don't think
No
but I'm sure he's fine so that's
interesting that part actually yeah I
guess the ear cutting is what led to me
seeing him maybe
Sam we're gonna see some of the other
branches here lay back maybe we could
take it my surprise
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's like all tough
when they leave and close the door Julia
tell me what happened if we didn't get
to see it either time so curious how
much money they have
now we just have to wait and see what
they want to do with us it's ominous
baby up fade to black on that yeah I
think this is where the second part of
the chapter began maybe yeah well it may
also be like storm is like like the
overarching category and then you take a
part of it I think that's how they I
believe that's probably by that way hold
on to is like chapters but then ever
like see that makes sense yeah it's in a
while in a while since I played it so
long although I still recommend it guys
if you haven't played it chat well great
game at least one of us can get on their
boat get some help
let's do it if you can distract them I
can get on em I'm gonna try to run away
of it dealing with a gun won't even
realize until I'm long gone seven
seconds I can get out through the window
we gotta break these off first to loud
they'll hear it we're gonna break them
during the Thunder that's what we did
wrong last time I was like re right
trigger we're just waiting for the
Thunder you know I just hate it when the
frog came up okay that's interesting I
didn't even think about it
that makes sense
two three
five six all you missed it
she had to come and help you guys was a
just get to the boat yeah I just hit it
when it came up last time think about it
alright we're going for the boat the
Great Escape voting I like this is a
cool thing that's like algorithm thing
here
I loved how they made sure they still
got that line inaudible ooh nice yeah
that was the plan was to escape right
right now oh my god will you really get
in there
[Music]
all right
we're out Oh
[Music]
very differently oh no we can't catch
him with this old junker bring them
downstairs
oh no use a TV you have to do that's
like that's a pretty radical change now
write him like it that him being gone
yeah I mean you know obviously he'll
show up later but like the brother still
hasn't come out yet
oh yeah he's still hiding you yeah this
is super different for us already
sit no I hate people deco similar to
stop film la gusta me maracas
[Music]
right goob he booked it peace out of
there
Olsen come here
Oh interesting so well I was up top
before so I didn't get this scene about
them actually seeing the the note with
the manchurian gold which one of you is
going to tell me about this and Korean
do
[Music]
[Music]
this is about an hour into the game
Jackson and then take the entire plate
I'm going it's gonna be about three to
four hours okay so all right shut the
[ __ ] up
belligerent I live break that gangsta
[ __ ]
the other cm so the situation sister I'm
just gonna say it
this has gotta be in on this she needs
guys they travel in the same waters
she's a captain they barely laid a hand
on her
oh dang I bet you told them about the
mentor he is accusations cahoots
well obviously that's not cool man if
you're mine how did you come up with
this [ __ ] how [ __ ] dare you
over privilege [ __ ] you're all in
this together
[Music]
paranoia curious if this is a work oh
you're just trying to like cause a
distraction
oh yes that one
[Music]
just in my microphone catch us to polio
oh she is
[Music]
find out the longest um is gonna laugh
you try anything Christopher Nasheed
says it's their birthday happy birthday
to you got two names your name so I'm
not sure which one so happy birthday to
both update over
Jackson I don't know what that character
is in or not we haven't seen him yeah
big ask for help right ask how bad the
storm is well we asked for help last
time so let's go for the storm hey just
for busting any information about this
storm you can give us it's a little bit
hairy out here over for those asking
this is manna madam is out on Easter do
yes play in one of the chapters here
from the demo build okay hey okay out
here we can have a look up a bus and
drops of rain thanks for the info we'll
see you for drinks back on shore in a
couple of days
and super calm that time it's like I
don't know I definitely wouldn't in real
life oh okay all right let's try not to
go flying here
[Music]
like what the bad guys are like and
vulnerable to all of this there we go
[Music]
just cut it all
what's up Willie welcome to the street
so gonna help people that's
can't not help people exactly first
Julie hey move it
now yeah the brothers still just hanging
out down there somewhere I know like
what brother but I guess that's okay
lady he stays hit and then he can come
to the rest of you later hopefully you
would know about Brad is he hiding
somewhere
well hope he doesn't drown have you
stuck oh yeah look he might drink yeah
okay drought we need to get him out of
there he's not safe right buddy come out
oh man what did we just kill them all
right there is we did the multiplayer
earlier we might run through it again
after this now that we've seen more of
the story I also missed a bunch of wrong
this light got me overnight
yeah I was prepared
[Music]
there's all the info for people who need
it yeah
so should we run through this again and
try different stuff because that story
was like vastly different from the first
time we ran through it yeah Brad didn't
show up till the end or the character
got away so yeah I'm not down okay cool
let me maybe we'll split up to choose
different characters than we did last
time I close out of the game because I
didn't want it to UM lag up the stream
there we go let me just make sure
[Music]
yeah all right cool so let's try it the
multiplayer again let's see if we can
maybe even find more alternate things
yeah let's see so why don't you invite
me this
but yeah pretty good I mean this is a
preview chapter and it's definitely got
me more interested in what the rest of
the game is gonna be like so oops didn't
tada okay new story everyone sees my
great Arrested Development reference of
a name alright I let's see you were try
that last time right yes okay so I'll be
Charlie this time sounds good alright
I'm ready now for those of you watching
you will see both of our screens but
you're only gonna hear our audio from
Tony's because both audio is together is
gonna be a little crazy yeah it'd be a
bit much but that's why we have the
subtitles on yeah I agree
Nathan jod I do think the game looks
good and looks better than until done I
mean I guess that's just the progress of
time right it's been a couple years they
can make a prettier game now but uh yeah
I think it looks real good all right
take three new perspectives we're we're
knowledgeable now yeah
now you'll be the one going outside
during the window yeah I gotta hope I
land all my foot time in Venice
what I gotta make sure is when we go to
break the glass
yeah it's uh
we gotta press it on seven like I was
thinking like seven and then go it's you
gotta hit it on seven that's when I
messed up before
[Music]
I'm ready I'm prepared I don't know what
to expect now though played this
perspective before all right I got a gun
to my face
I got one of two QuickTime events there
had that cursor but I wasn't sure what
you once I got it centered oh well
oh wait hold on I think my subtitles
turned off oh no they're cool okay well
right back in I like that it sinks you
up to come back I mean I guess it would
have to if you're playing seriously but
that's very handy it's like when you're
playing rock band you pause and like
gives you that count in for the song
starts yep always very handy
[Music]
she's freaking out all right Homa ungag
you appreciate it okay
Oh
that would really hurt all that I do
I'll return the favor
all right let's see what we've got to
see three I think just three
[Music]
believe in the captain I'm not gonna gag
in captain
there's no nice it's got a little bit of
like dried blood wonder kids icons
before this chapter yes it's probably
Conrad hit him or something it can be
played that way uh AG nines but that's
the movie the theater motoring yeah yeah
where you kind of get past the
controllers you make decisions but so
from this perspective though we get
maybe the fish two different views of
the action so it's some play the
characters really just get to see
different pace how was that good news
good news first are such an idiot Jesus
[Music]
we have to get free
that's still been my priority each time
let's get us out of here right
[Music]
loading
that's so crazy but the last time we ran
through it
Alex was like you're in on this Oh why
was the Queen's engine I just got
punched all right I got my kicking I'd
be back for you later yeah that was that
was very different him yelling at her
yeah that was the last thing I was
thinking yeah nobody lady no rush now
drink the rest of it you can go bleep
yourself you piece of bleep
oh I got the like low angle shot of that
one yeah I felt that one from here
what's happening watching you getting
beat up I know I'm gonna
Julia Conrad
what are they talking about who kicks a
[ __ ] what I feel every one of them hmm
y-yeah okay why are they so interested
in Fliss because she's the captain so
what this must be able to I was thinking
about before when he started accusing
her right
and I see nothing
like I've used that response to a few
times
oh just not saying it right I was think
that's interesting that that's a choice
oh this is where she got the little
safety scissors from
[Laughter]
I don't own one now I feel like I need
you just in case I need to break myself
free but I'm I'm a mess here anyways so
[Music]
Marcus it is both if you play couch pop
you can pass the controller and decide
on decisions together if you're playing
online which we are actually doing now
we're on two separate machines here then
you will actually get different
perspectives from different characters
this line again yeah they like
guaranteed you're gonna have that line
in there no matter which way you play it
one of the writers is like no this one
every time it's right this line is it's
the best line yeah I mean I wonder where
you know I didn't
I hope you sorry see I guess you only
see the brother if the ear thing happens
right yeah it's very interesting there's
plenty of stuff like that in until dawn
like very specific stuff like that
yes men while the game does have simply
taken by surprise
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I agree pika
it looks a lot like until dawn except
like you know a little better and
graphically that is and I'm also very
didn't touch me about our parents what
how much money they have
yeah I can tell further down the road in
this game
all these little decisions are probably
gonna really shake things out I think
it's every every time when it says a
bearing changed I think I think that's
the big one course like this is gonna
really make a difference but there were
smaller ones than in until dawn to like
they're very specific things like you
had to make or like you would die
there's some characters and until dawn
that were really really hard to actually
like
storms give them through the whole thing
alive something really hard for some
characters yeah it's a speed boat he's
got a gun has to be a way we can take
him out at least one of us can get on
their boat get some help
what do we want to do that's that's your
call that's what say nothing let's see
what we what I see what happens in you
think seven seconds I can get out
through the window
okay these are precise to go we're gonna
break them during all right you ready
yeah let's do it
oh we got to hit it on seven here's the
trick yes here I'll climb out this
window take a look around
um guys destroy see couple uh yes so
jack is Jackie's sorry I don't know how
I'm not username there yes there are
relationship status things and
personality traits you'll you'll see
them pop up anytime they change oh yes
what did we both I really got it yeah we
got it
I definitely pressed on so alright well
she got it open anyway Thank You Julia
and Godfather 55 this is oh my god do
stuff
yes Godfather 55 this is it's not
episodic but they're releasing sort of
anthology series and this just happens
to be the first one of those games and
it'll be like it's like three to four
hours long they say
we'll be making more alone I got a
hostage now got a hell car
oh man it's getting heated out on the
poop deck
ooh we got a hostage - yeah let's go
where we ended up before yeah with
remembered don't go for the gun that's a
trick
yeah had to be don't get your baby by
the gun mmm let's finish this that's
that's pretty hardcore
actually we got both of them held
hostage don't take me on your escape
dang those are my only two options
all right struck that's Cape I guess I
do we prepare the dish
all right
[Music]
dodged a bullet or do I let him get
smoked from the back my head no no no
I'm gonna I'm gonna go for that you
don't have to worry about it actually I
just maybe not okay
thank goodness I watched you do this
because I knew is gonna be why I also
kind of I rushed him to with the gun
which hopefully threw it off a little
bit downstairs beat us we pressed it on
seven I know where we did I swear I was
so very deliberately like six sit no
stop film la gusta me maracas
right so I think from here I take on the
role of Flis yeah yeah so SEC and this
Manchurian come here
and at some point Conrad I'm sure will
show up and just be the hero you know
hopefully which one of you is going to
tell me about this man finally Curie I
will do such a pirate has everything and
Chewie and gold
I haven't been belowdecks at this part
of the Curie's your brother is out
that's true
um I am Not sure Jackie I don't believe
the character be gone for good my guess
is that well if he doesn't die out on
the waves obviously that could happen
come right he can take care of himself
all right my guess is that it's possible
he could die out there on the waves but
I feel like if you play your cards right
he will give me a play alert the Coast
Guard or at some point reunite with with
the rest of the gang and kind of rescue
some abilities that's what I would guess
the situation sister cuz I haven't a lot
until dawn somebody would disappear and
then come back and just like hey how
long just no big deal not accused Jesus
hey the PC was quick to question
fruitless
oh no I missed it it's too oh yeah
take little events like that I'm like
wondering how does that change the story
I don't think this radically does but
yeah that is correct
flight this is not the beginning of the
game this takes place about an hour into
its going on Alex
Check Into yeah okay
yeah I'm fine now I have to decide do I
tell the people on the comm we're safe
or no and talking to you just please
take the gun off of us it's making
everybody nervous and nervous people do
stupid things get all blood on your
hands see
[Music]
and would you want
I said nothing and he's upset now I got
kind of like cut off there so I wonder
if like the more time you take up there
it gives me more time to talk down oh I
got hit in the head with Friday
that's just funny that's like some loony
toony stop right there that's
hey see this is man banana from the team
that made until dawn same kind of
gameplay different game
Oh see what happens if I just hold on
instead of helping you guys
[Music]
you guys make it out
Hey movie looks like it kind of changes
maybe the order the amount amount of
both them the really the real like
radical changes come from that bearing
updated thing
what the [ __ ] out not the tongue your
job looking after number one real slow
great leadership place man he loves that
it's not happy
a sports this is a demo bill pool game
is out on the 30th
I'm immune yeah we know about
Oh Dame
Phil would not want
alright that was our third run-through
like we I think we've seen a lot of what
that has to offer there yeah make new
choices with different outcomes yeah we
definitely saw different parts of story
every time we ran through it which was
pretty cool
yeah we got that last round uh we got
two of their guys as our hostages the
first time I think one of our guys was
held mean we had one of theirs so yeah a
lot of permutations yeah I still I still
ended up missing a lot of my quick
diamonds even though I was like semi
prepared for it already
what's it's it's a very small window to
hit some of them so even if you're just
like for a second you're like hey this
thing oh no it's like I conked in the
head with a frying pan that was pretty
funny so yeah there's also this is the
movie night we were speaking about
before where you can play with two to
five friends but you just share the
controller and like hand it over you
know have a little group thing I think
the idea is you can you let you pick the
characters you want to represent and
then you make those characters choices I
think is the way that works that makes
sense that sounds like a lot of fun too
actually yeah
games where you can kind of have your
whole group involved you know that's why
other games like draw 'full and all the
jack box games are really fun totally
like couch co-op type game I'm a big TKO
fan noise yeah I still want to buy one
of the tees that we make from Tiki
haven't done it I actually have a couple
friends who have done that vadym yeah
that was fun this was a demo build so if
you're like wow it's too short
there's only demo the full games coming
out on the 30th so definitely check it
out if you liked what you saw I've seen
like screenshots and you know the
trailer and everything and there's
definitely way more scarier thing yeah
it's kind of supernatural yeah I mean
that's that's one until dawn did like it
was there was thriller stuff there was
like supernatural stuff and they did
they pulled like all and like every
horror movie trope you can imagine into
the game so I'm very very curious as to
what else they'll throw into this as it
goes on
wondering if we would get anything new
out of one final run-through I don't
know because I feel like I kind of made
different decisions every time we okay
well why don't you why don't you you
want you go through it then go do it
okay all right I'll do a solo run I am
going to officially close out of my side
of the game go on fullscreen here just
so the PC can breathe a little bit
I think streaming on here and playing
the game was like making it freak out
that's fine
possibly we made it all right all right
one more make all the calls this time
you got it
play low
see what happens sorry but yeah surely
maybe we'll actually get the hitting the
window thing right this time
exactly we have yet to do that correctly
one time
I would totally like take a trip on this
boat though not this not this one that's
being overrun with pirates but like it's
been a couple days I got on a boat like
this that'd be fun I'd be ready
oh that's where the comes from that he
has think about that that means but if
you missed it then I assume he wouldn't
have that cut later on
right so alex has been real annoying as
an AI and so I'm just gonna leave him
where he is okay just leave him bound
yeah all right
that is your decision to make this time
all right we gotta switch it up i mean
ii take tape off he's already accusing
Flis sorry to think about it got useless
got you girl but hey what if she is in
on it I know and he took my taint box
use I might I need answers Fliss
police alex was complying with me um
yeah was I supposed to know they'd have
no sense of humor
now I'm really curious why he did I know
right I don't believe so Jackie I
believe by default you're gonna be
bouncing around through different
characters that's the way until dawn
works too
you bounce between all the different
teams
[Music]
free-flight areata has an interesting
point maybe you have to go on six and
not seven because it's torment gotten
closer maybe that's possible
hey like real real strict attention game
ever competed finally get it right get
to see what this game is like when you
actually yeah what's that somehow be
like so radically like that changes
everything like that's how we win the
fight and everything would be funny
are they gonna do to us
well teacher you know he's right about
that
I gotta say I don't like that he's
getting you know all madoff lists but
he's definitely right about this being a
very dangerous situation
[Music]
you're gonna regret this piece of [ __ ]
you're gonna run it himself
yeah I really don't think she's in on
this oh no cuz she would have no idea of
knowing that's what they were nice dodge
he's still kicked it for me even though
I didn't untie him and I did not uncock
him but nobody knows they're out here
little lady you all alone with us now
let's make the most of it you can go
[ __ ] you're the little lady
[Music]
get tough punches pretty solid punches
though dang a third one just for funsies
let's see let's you know what we didn't
get our ear cut off in a while
oh yeah you know how to treat a lady
right
[Music]
yeah there it is
Oh we'll see the brother this time I
guess all right
see what happens still down
easy
I'll say nothing with science see what
happens
right flip but okay your ears intact my
treat
whoo I'm reckless no like your
relationship with dip with Flis dipped a
little bit maybe it looks like mm she
doesn't think you're as tough maybe but
you're generous now what's that
maybe there's a little bit somebody was
asking about the traits and in
relationships earlier if they're there
it is those are still here well
everyone's a little man or a little lady
apparently
oh okay
okay that's where we got that so we
found another way to find the brother
without getting our ear cut off okay all
these permutations I like it
ha real challenges is getting the
Thunder way right that's been the
hardest one so far
oh Jesus Conrad
that's a really gnarly black guy he's
got going on here so slow we get to here
one more time
every run-through I don't think they're
gonna hear they have an influence
flusher seems to be getting buddy-buddy
with him so yeah he's hiding he's okay
all right
era
all right don't let them see your hands
once we get Julia back maybe we could
take them by surprise
badly Antipholus you deny caramel get my
bliss bag at all [ __ ] [ __ ] behind
ya Julia tell me what happened they
asked about her parents what how much
money they have
all right gang's all free I don't know
if you'll get it playing alone but when
I was playing I got a chance to stab the
guy again when he came through the door
[Music]
I know I just want one of these
playthroughs or we actually like killing
the bad guys I'd be really nice it'd be
nice I don't know however I failed at
every eight seconds storms eight miles
away we came here on a boat maybe we can
take it yeah yeah it's a speed boat he's
got a gun well at least one of us can
get on their boat get some help yeah I
just realized I likes didn't bother to
put on pants and any of these
playthroughs you don't get an option
just put on some pants we gotta take
them down
they can try to fight back but if we had
the gun they'd be forced to surrender
seven seconds I can get out through the
window we gotta break these off first
did you loud I'll hear it we're gonna
break them during the Thunder yeah good
call alright we got this you guys
climber on the side in here okay we'll
take him from the other side don't leave
us here okay we're gonna go on six
two three four five six
okay so you have to present on six let
it go oh yeah II kind of gone a little
weird but okay I waited like a little
bit after six okay but we got it finally
Oh finally
now we truly had the element of surprise
yeah with a little heartbeat game now
[Music]
I still walk over there
well that didn't work
[Music]
all right okay
there's really no other way though from
here it's amateur hour over here listen
I got this
let me handle it
okay all right you got the other one if
that was me
we should have both just slit their
throats already and then everyone gang
up on this last line I mean that gun no
we're outnumbered someone might have to
deal let's finish this trying to kill me
I want to take one person out I know
this is the bait but but we're going for
it anyways
[Applause]
I mean we already know about
Alex this is crazy our boat okay my we
played once player before you can play
the game single player you can play the
game show up and you all just kind of
take turns making decisions about the
invert seed oh wait did someone get shot
there a shot went off okay but oh no
Alex that over pal oh this one very
differently
Oh No
[Music]
oh wow alright playthrough wait Julius
well heard things stood still there
maybe the bullets kind of grazed her Wow
so sorry so dancer cause you came why
you can play the game single-player you
can pass the controller and sort of make
decisions per character like and couch
co-op to you or we were playing earlier
you can actually play online
cooperatively and you'll actually the
story will branch and you'll actually
see different perspectives of different
characters right now currently yes we
did to run through this multiplayer and
then now to run through single-player
and we have seen different things every
time it's cool
we saw Julia get shot me oh boy wow me
dramatic I didn't think it was gonna
happen but it
[Music]
which one of you is going to tell me is
office Manchurian good GG this part
isn't very horror like but we've seen
like from the trailer and some
screenshots that there are oh she's
alive okay so it just kind of she got
grazed in the head somehow okay that's
interesting now she's the injured one as
opposed to Connor or yeah well GG if
you've played until dawn there are parts
of until dawn that are definitely it
like they build up to that or it's not
immediately horror there's some more
like thriller stuff first and this I
imagine is gonna go the same way because
there's like that whole there's like
that weird mermaid creature that's in
like the streamers
my guess is once they get on the big
giant boat that's when that stuff's
going to start happening what are you
thinking this is just about you know
they're not gonna tip their hat too much
in this previous you know
there is no harm in just talking you
wanna talk
keep the volume down hey come on we're
just passing time no big deal
keep quiet
captain says shut your mouth you shut
your mouth oh I missed it we've never
hit anything
you come with me
actually apps light air possibly one of
the guys might have died
Danny I think his name was might have
gotten stabbed there I don't see him
currently we'll see if we see him later
all right do we comply this time it up
to you your call last time I said closer
in your hair and he definitely still got
man yeah Duke of Milan requesting
weather update
over there was an interesting option
[Music]
like if we complied and then on the next
one there was like an emergency it's a
little bit hairy out here over
[Music]
desperate my my tour has been a little
difficult not exactly going as planned
oh I thought she was just gonna like
spit it out like worry we are kidnapped
hey that was Neil yeah in Petoskey I
don't believe anyone has died yet we'll
see none of that none of the key Kurt
oh I miss Oh I looked at the chat hey
homeboy saved me though Wow okay
interesting
oh I wonder if I would have like ratted
them out and not he would lay
fifth flavor right there's too many
questions after I'd like
I did a back of my old freelance days I
did a guy until dawn how to get
everybody for alive I had to go for like
every single option just to know for
sure
[Music]
I'll help you guys we're all upset Emil
as I am right now
Hey okay oh yeah it's so alive no Julie
I just got the raised and the brother
wait where's the brother okay there's
gonna be there
thanks I guess wait did we get the
brother yeah or did he not show up
oh hey still hiding okay Brad
okay keep a lid on it it could be our
ticket out okay this is new Brad
stays hidden better off down there than
with these psychos
oh yeah great he could get killed down
there rats a big move they'll be okay
little man little lady big boy oh no
what if the brother dies are we getting
slammed
I wonder if it's because in it and until
dawn there were a couple characters
like one or two would die early on but
goes to fun like it took well before
they could actually die
ready for you this time
yes and why is the same studio that made
until dawn
they're doing they're gonna be doing a
whole like anthology
well we'll never know what happens to
the brother in that run-through not
until not until the 30th perhaps not for
another 15 days yeah
however from just that one chapter and
you know we played through it like four
times I still felt pretty interested
like every single run-through because
there are a lot of different options and
choices yeah we saw many things Julia
got shot and then the last one that was
a big change Wow
this final run-through I actually wasn't
expecting it to be too too different
mm-hmm but that one was probably more
different than all the runs we've done
so yeah it's some pretty significant
stuff happened there yeah that was
awesome and I was ton of fun shout outs
to the devs for hooking it up with this
preview build yes thank you I'm very
very much looking forward to the full
game now and this was nice this is like
dipping my toes in the water cuz I had
mentally prepared myself to get super
scared and I read that it was like a
horror game but this is easing me into
it so maybe around the 30th you might
see us playing the full game once it is
out if you would like to get your hands
on this make sure you pre-order it now
because you can do so tomorrow we will
be live with community Fridays for MK 11
Ben and John Luke will be playing
matches against you guys and also will
be checking out some nightwolf so make
sure you tune in tomorrow for that
action but until next time we will see
you guys later bye